you and I always chat about your various
relationships your search for mr. right
yes I've met some of your candidates
[Music]
every now and then you enlist me like
the creepy older brother to like come by
and check the guy up tell us there's a
new boyfriend I hear tell let's talk
about that guy who is he he's really
actually I mean no it's okay it's okay
get him young get him young while her
personality is still forming together
for a year and a half is that a
guitarist international he was playing
yes instead of you busting my mojo it
was my father who kept coming up during
the wedding saying who's that who's that
who's that and I'm just like you need to
go away Jerry Channel right so I can get
my mojo on with this guy this Josh Josh
you hadn't yet no but you told me about
it you said that you were dating a
guitarist and and I said what's his name
Josh and I immediately thought okay
that's my rival Josh that's why I
remember these things immediately it was
burned into my brain that that Josh must
be destroyed josh is you've been dating
for a year and a half that's good I did
tell you you said that we could come
over so when we're done socially
distancing they want to come over for
dinner
that'd be great I want to have you over
oh you got enough time for another
another wardrobe change
kristin chenoweth this is I think a
historic moment multiple wardrobe
changes during her zoom interview and
again very attractive Kristin Chenoweth
is now undressing and then dressing just
off camera just over that way where I
can't see
again probably creepy for a guy here in
quarantine in a room alone we'll be
talking about it changing she comes here
she comes let's clean it up people here
we go here she comes
oh my god
that's a homework onesie I said
Christmas onesie cuz I get a bit of
Christmas movie this year their Hall of
Fame movie yes so they gave me the ones
I loved ones you looks fantastic it
looks good it's comfortable additional
elastic waistband I feel guilty for
eating the captain and I'm comfortable
you're you realize you're regressing to
childhood you're eating children's food
and you're dressed right now as a child
who needs to go to sleep I think third
grade I think you're ready for third
grade so the onesie you're a fan of a
onesie yes especially I can get mine in
the children's apartment at Target
because think about it I'm 411 where am
I going to shop the kids defer so on
tour before this whole thing problems
occurred which we know what we're
talking about here yeah I got a onesie
at Target
it was Winnie the Pooh and I actually
would have put it on now but it's in the
dirty clothes because I'm wearing it all
the time please set your dog NBA
basketball team Thunder yeah it's like
thunder how are you yeah this is what's
happening to late night
I'm bringing my dog onesie and I'm
bringing a captain and crystal why yeah
and again if you're not getting paid by
these companies you should be getting
paid by these I know this was on my
piano oh that's great I like that is
that your that's your reading for the
night yeah